[Musica]
Buonasera
[Applauso]
Buona buonasera a tutti Salve
allora Io come sapete ho giocato a rugby
quando era lo stadio
la prima cosa che facevo era questo
questo adesso va a mia moglie
Però quando io stavo allo stadio Io
cercavo sempre nelle tribune le persone
che erano andate lì quel giorno per me
che potevano essere i miei genitori che
venivano poco qualche amico per Io con
questo gesto gli facevo capire che io
quel giorno Avrei giocato per loro di
aver lasciato la vita per loro era un
modo anche di farli sentire con me in
campo poi un'altra cosa che mi ricordo
molto quando guardavo le tribune era che
lei tifoserie sono mescolate nel nostro
sport che deve un qualcosa di
incredibile che ancora abbiamo e che ed
è bellissimo e unico
Poi però quando guardate in campo Vedevi
la faccia dei giocatori c'erano che
aveva paura
Chi sapeva quello che andava a fare quel
giorno
Chi era felice di essere lì perché amava
quello che stava facendo
Poi
l'arbitro chiamava La Mischia Per chi
non lo sapesse La Mischia sono 900 kg
che ti arrivano davanti e altri 900 kg
che arrivano dietro
Dicono che sia molto duro
Ma io me lo ricordo come l'impatto più
bello che mai abbia mai fatto io nella
mia vita è stato una poesia Molto bella
la nostra posizione più o meno era
questa era così di fianco a me c'era il
tallonatore dell'altro lato c'era il
Pilone sinistro dietro di noi C'erano le
seconde linee che ci avevano il compito
peggiore mettere la testa tra le chiappe
dei nuovi prima linea
bruttissimo lavoro e dietro c'erano le
terze linee
Quando tu stavi lì c'erano istanti che
duravano un'eternità
io mi ricordo che c'era un mix di odori
lì dentro veramente c'era un mix di
strada
e crema e crema riscaldante quella che
sa di canfora poi c'era un silenzio che
a me mi ricorda molto quel silenzio dei
film di guerra no dove il generale alza
la spada e carica tutti verso il loro
destino c'era un silenzio così perché tu
andavi a sbattere lì dentro quando tu
alzavi la testa il tuo avversario stava
qua e tu guardavi negli occhi suoi
vedevi la sua paura ma riusciva a vedere
pure la tua
e allora ne sono chiesto che quest'anno
al Telex Bergamo il tema è l'ossigeno
Allora ho cercato visto che non sono uno
scienziato non lo sono mai stato non lo
sarò mai ho pensato
quale sarà stato il mio ossigeno tutti
questi anni Allora ho pensato se La
Mischia Sarà stato il mio ossigeno
Ma no forse non lo Stato
poi nel ricordo che
da bambino avevo un sogno
essere il miglior giocatore del rugby
del mondo Io ho iniziato a giocare verso
le 17/18 anni e allora mi ricordo che
dormivo con la palla abbracciato tutte
le sere perché pensavo che quello mi
avrebbe fatto giocare più velocemente
l'avrei imparato più velocemente Era un
sogno e allora per poter giocare a rugby
io dovevo andare via dall'Argentina
dovevo venire in Italia perché qui è il
rugby era professionista no E dicono che
quando tu ami quello che fai non
lavorerai un giorno io non ho mai
lavorato
e quel giorno io ero felice perché tu
immagina 19 di 20 anni Tu vai a vivere
da solo
potevi cucinare la sala i piatti in giro
che nessuno ti avrebbe detto niente
potevi lasciare i vestiti in giro per
tutta la casa la casa tua nessuno ti
diceva niente potevi arrivare a
qualsiasi orario invece quando ero su
quell'aereo che ero seduto così e
guardavo le insegna della cintura di
sicurezza
quando si è spenta però mi ricordo che
sono andato abbastanza veloce quasi
correndo in bagno e mi sono messo a
piangere
ma non era un pianto di tristezza Era un
pianto di consapevolezza io stavo
diventando uomo perché per inseguire i
tuoi sogni tu devi lasciare delle cose
per la strada e io stavo lasciando i
miei affetti la mia famiglia i miei
amici
Allora
sarà stato il mio sogno il mio ossigeno
tutti questi anni no
forse no Allora ho pensato ho ripensato
ancora che io ho giocato in alcune
squadre tutta la mia carriera alcune più
forti e altre meno forti quelle più
forti ovviamente tutte queste squadre
avevano un qualcosa in comune
avevano degli obiettivi quelle più forti
ovviamente L'obiettivo era vincere il
campionato può arrivare tra i primi
quelle meno forti Ovviamente
io parlo adesso dalle l'esempio di
quando abbiamo cominciato a giocare i
Sei nazioni con l'Italia Per chi non lo
sapesse il nazione è un torneo di rugby
che si gioca qui in Europa dove giocano
l'Inghilterra L'Irlanda e Scozia del
Galles la Francia e noi l'Italia
e questo torneo ovviamente c'è il premio
di chi vince il Sei Nazioni ma c'è un
altro premio simbolico che è molto
brutto che si chiama il famoso cucchiaio
di legno
è simbolico questo si dà alla squadra
che arriva per ultimo e non ha vinto
nessuna partita per noi i primi anni
ovviamente era il nostro obiettivo era
non prendere questo cucchiaio di legno
poi immaginatevi quando prendevamo il
cucchiaio di legno come ci prendevano in
giro che dicevano che gli italiani
avevano mangiato la pasta col cucchiaio
di legno sono stati anni molto duri
Però ovviamente noi non abbiamo vinto ci
siamo tolti qualche soddisfazione ma il
nostro obiettivo erano un passo alla
volta erano non prendere quel cucchiaio
di legno dopo cercare di arrivare quinti
quarti non l'abbiamo vinto ma abbiamo
fatto quello che era il massimo per le
capacità di quelle squadre allora
saranno stati i miei obiettivi e delle
mie squadre il mio ossigeno tutti questi
anni
No forse no Allora ho pensato pensato ho
ripensato Io ho pensato ancora pensato
tantissimo questa volta
quasi più che a scuola
mi sono ricordato che
quando sono arrivato in Inghilterra c'è
una regola
che a me mi ha cambiato la vita e mi ha
fatto vedere il mio sport molto
diversamente questa regola diceva
che tutti dovevi alzare molto
velocemente da terra e voi Mi direte che
regola è e invece questa regola
raccoglie rappresenta tutto quello che è
lo spirito del rugby perché nel rugby
quando tu vieni placcato e vai per terra
si alza prima di te quello Cosa vuol
dire che le altre squadre in 15 la tua
in 14 Allora per noi quello non poteva
succedere e tu vedevi la gente che chi
si rompe un braccio chi ci aveva il naso
rotto chi chi stava male perché aveva
preso una botta tornava indietro e non
importava cosa per restare con la sua
squadra e quando tu vedevi quel tuo
compagno che faceva quello tu eri in
obbligo di farlo perché
questo entusiasmo all'entusiasmo è
contagioso la motivazione personale e le
regole devono essere regole fatte dalle
squadre stesse alle quali le squadre
deve credere deve essere come il credo
della squadra e tu devi morire Per
quella regola lì
Allora Saranno state le regole di
squadra tutti questi anni è il mio
ossigeno No no non sono state
e parlando di regole di squadra adesso
mi viene da ridere perché fa ridere
quando io sono arrivato in Inghilterra
c'è un'altra regola che io non sapevo
chi c'erano due spogliatoio le sue
spogliatoio dei nuovi arrivati tipo io e
lo spogliatoio delle leggende di quelle
che stavano in quel club da tanti anni
dove sarà andato io
Sì sono andato quello che non dovevo
andare ma io non lo sapevo questo però
quando sono arrivato lì non sapendo io
mi sono seduto un esperto io sentivo un
clima un po' stile non erano tutti mi
guardavano male sai quando tagli proprio
con l'aria taglia con una forbice taglia
l'aria uguale ho detto Vabbè sarò
antipatico agli italiani non lo so non
sapevo non capivo sono andato a fare
morale sono andato a fare il mio primo
allenamento
le ho prese tantissime
non ne ho mai preso così tanto in vita
mia come quel giorno lì ogni volta che
prendevo la panameravano due o tre Ma
perché dico questo perché io credo che
oggi ci siano due tipi di fiducia la
fiducia personale e la fiducia
professionale e questo ad esempio
perfetto per Per far sì capire le
persone che il mio errore non ha
indagato la fiducia professionale il mio
errore di entrare lo spogliatoio ho
sbagliato non ha fatto sì che loro mi
giudicassero prima di vedermi in campo
hanno aspettato a vedere se io
professionalmente potevo onorare e
vestire la maglia loro e me lo ricordo
come si fosse oggi perché finito
quell'allenamento quelle persone ostili
E che me le avevano dato di santa
ragione durante l'allenamento sono
venuti meno guardato in faccia e me lo
ricordo ancora in faccia così mi hanno
dato la mano e mi ha detto Benvenuto al
nostro Club E perché dico questo io
perché penso che oggi le persone mettono
molto di più la fiducia personale a
quella professionale ma se io e te
abbiamo gli obiettivi e delle regole non
dobbiamo essere amici ma L'esperienza mi
dice che con gli anni tu diventi Quella
fiducia professionale diventa personale
perché tu credi nelle stesse cose hai
gli stessi valori ma non lo sai ancora
Allora
sarà stata la fiducia
il mio ossigeno tutti questi anni
vediamo
no bravi No non è stato Allora voglio
tornare un attimo alla mischia a quelli
ingaggio
quando tu hai visto la tua paura lì e
l'arbitro chiama quell'ingngaggio tu sei
in bilico e quando chiama
quell'ingngaggio tu hai Ma il tuo corpo
si arrugginisce perché tu hai verso un
impatto imminente e quando stai andando
tu cominci a pensare dove devo mettere
il braccio dove devo mettere a testa
come devo mettere le gambe ed è lì che
arriva la paura l'incertezza ce la farò
ma in quelle stesso istante però tutte
ricordi che di fianco a te scelta
allenatore dell'altro lato c'è il Pilone
e dopo ci sono le seconde linee dopo le
terze linee il film cambia tu sei più
forte di prima perché vada come vada con
l'ingaggio tu non sei solo tu c'hai la
tua squadra e quando sarai in difficoltà
la sotto perché lì sotto sei in
difficoltà perché quando stai qua C'hai
la testa del Pilone qua e l'altezza del
tallonatore qua Tu non puoi parlare tu
devi sentire la tua squadra deve essere
in sintonia con essa ed è lì e lì ho
capito
che il mio ossigeno tutti questi anni è
stata la mia squadra
io nelle squadre sono diventato uomo ho
imparato
a guardare in faccia e a gestire le mie
paure incertezze
e per quello credo che
il gruppo del lavoro dovrebbe diventare
come una squadra il gruppo dei nostri
amici dovrebbe diventare come una
squadra la nostra famiglia
dovrebbe diventare una squadra con
regole io obiettivi fatte dalla famiglia
stessa e rispettate con l'amore che si
ha per la maglia la maglia della tua di
famiglia
Io penso che noi dovremo cambiare un
pochettino di più e il paradigma dell'io
al noi e diventare tutti i più squadra
e prima di finire vi voglio lasciare con
qualcosa perché chi viene deve lasciare
un qualcosa e io mi voglio lasciare con
questo
A parte che sono stato il primo che ha
fischiato
è allora
pensate che questo pallone sia la nostra
vita no E questo siano i problemi che
noi troveremo
sarebbe troppo facile No torna sempre
alle mani la vita non è come questo
pallone Rotondo
e il secondo bellissimo
la vita è più come questo pallone qua
perché tu non sai mai dover rimbalzerà
tu non sai mai che piega prenderà la tua
vita Tu non sai mai dove fare andrà Vedi
se ne va e se tu aspetti che lei si
fermi ti passeranno tutte le tue
occasioni della vita davanti Allora devi
fare come facciamo noi quando la palla
cade per terra tutti devi buttare su
questa palla devi fermare il gioco devi
fermare la tua vita ma ricordati che se
tu non puoi fermare quella palla ci sono
altri 14 energumeni che si eviteranno a
fermare quella palla per te perché
questa è la nostra squadra e questo deve
essere il nostro ossigeno Grazie
Grazie mille